guys like a satoshi nakamoto of boring
businesses so cool um what's up how are
you man oh yeah your video went blank
for a second I'm great um I upgraded my
internet hopefully it looks better
called Comcast now paid 60 bucks a month
and just called them and with a click of
a button I paid them more money and my
internet was supposed to improve we'll
see if it happens like mad great great
business to be in
I'm excited to talk to you I feel like
it's been a little while I got a bunch
of random topics to talk about I don't
know how about you do you have anything
that was top of mind for you yeah well I
know about all this stuff that you or a
lot of the stuff that you have in here
right like I know it to the point of I
wasn't sure if I wrote it or you wrote
it that's for the best
ok great ok so I'm gonna start with
let's pick one that's that's interesting
okay so how about how about we start
with this one so somebody was somebody
tweeted this and I saw it and I was like
this is pretty smart so a lot of people
right now we're talking about
coronavirus how does the world gonna
change and lots of speculation I think
everybody sort of agrees ok handshakes
you know might go out the window for a
bit live sports you know it's gonna be a
little tough so there's there's some
things that we know we're gonna change
and there's some things that you can't
really predict they're sort of second
order effects and so somebody reached
out and they have put together this they
had like a group of people had put
together this thing called a second
order effects of coke kovin I thought it
was great I'm gonna find the PDF and I'm
gonna link it in the description here I
know one of the creators was this guy
that I've met one time super super smart
guy he created are you a Harry Potter
fan no but I know I mean I'm not not a
fan but I don't buy the stuff seem to
move so he created this site back in the
day called muggle net which was oh yeah
I know that guy he also created a oh my
god pop or what was it he's a viral
convey about what's not a ng pop but
he's yeah yeah yeah I know all about him
tell me his name
I'm trying to find out I can't believe I
forgot it every wife know some sparks so
they start of sports media yeah
and yeah yeah I know I know about him
well I think his business is the one
you're thinking about that's right so he
started a chain of viral websites and
they got really popular but like
everything in that era I bet it just
crapped like and but if I met this guy
once and I was like oh my god if I could
just bet on this guy's like lifetime
earnings I would bet right away like
this guy's really really sharp yeah he's
he's kind of like a little genius yeah I
like when you say because it means like
kind of hard to talk to like he's a
little GGC but when I read about him
like dude why are you doing these viral
sites like you'd do anything yeah and I
bet he will I bet he's gonna be one of
those people that transitions from like
yeah I first created these you know the
Harry Potter fan site that would be him
number one then I created this viral
Twitter account and these viral mean
websites oh and then I like solve
climate change like that's what this
guy's career should look like right all
goes well he's cool so he anyway what
about him in a group of people created
this thing that was like second-order
effects they were basically like okay
you know for example what's a
second-order effect so everyone knows a
first-order effect is coronavirus they
you know is is wild first-order effect
you shelter-in-place
okay but the second-order effect of that
is like our people can have more babies
our divorce is gonna go up because
you're at home is grocery delivery gonna
take off because of that and then
there's a good third order effect okay
if the grocery delivery takes off they
need to Hut you know instacart hiring
hundreds of thousands of delivery people
okay what happens when all those people
go to that job now they need a
healthcare system for a gig worker
becomes more important so there's like
these these knock-on effects and so for
a business person you want to think
about okay oftentimes the biggest impact
- the biggest opportunities are in the
second and third order effects because
you can start doing work now and then as
this plays out those things those
markets are growing rapidly but you can
kind of predict them so a classic
example of this was you probably know
this better than I do there's some story
like the highway system was built for
for something like it was built for I
don't know what it was like military
purposes or something like that but the
second-order effect was that like
Walmart basically it was like oh people
are gonna exit and want to get you know
buy stuff get little you know get food
get drinks blah so the whole retailers
got fast there yeah cars get faster the
retail system takes
because now there's a highway
interconnect system blah blah blah so
there's a second-order effects so one of
them that I just thought was kind of
interesting was this idea of drive-thru
and drive-in so now that you know movie
theaters are like short of going
bankrupt because all their chairs are so
close to each other that people like
people are going to go back to the
movies movies are already kind of
struggling and this might be the
knockout blow and so people are talking
about drive-in theaters is that gonna be
a thing I could see it I could see you
know sort of rising on top of that you
have drive-through so how do you use or
minimize contact well drive-through
caffeine so there's some coffee shops
that are like the photos I saw on
Twitter you know the line is out the
door I've never seen a line this long
except for chick-fil-a and so like
what's this for and it's basically just
drive-through caffeine and so I'm pretty
bullish on this if somebody was you know
right now they had like nine franchises
but they were doing well and they were a
drive-through coffee concept I would you
know be very very bullish on this thing
expanding and going from nine to 200
locations over the next two years
because I think the need for this is
gonna go up what do you think about that
okay so what do I think do I first of
all are people gonna change their
behavior forever let's let's talk about
that right like are shaking hands got to
go away um certainly now like I don't
want to do a lot of that stuff but is
that going to change your behavior
forever I don't know um what's it what's
in an out like what can we compare this
to like World War two I mean September
11th like when I see when I hear low
planes I get scared so like no no no TSA
clearance right so like you used to be
able to just walk into an airport take a
ticket that didn't even have your name
on it and board any plane and it took
you five minutes to get from the you
know check-in desk to to the gate and
now it's like yes you know security
buffer in an hour you have to have your
ID it's gotta have your name on it if
your name sounds a little sketchy hope
you're gonna come to this special room
and get checked that the world changed
forever from that sure but we're also
talking so the September 11th was
definitely like a lot of like force
change like TSA but then what we're
discussing is like unforced when you and
I see each other are we gonna hug are we
gonna high-five or we got a are we gonna
bow like you know
it's like yeah so like how far away are
we gonna say so I would imagine that
some of these consumer behaviors are a
little bit more analogous analogous
right to that I don't know man um will
we change I think so I think that at
least for three years something is gonna
change the question is what's gonna
change and how long is it gonna change
or is it gonna be sort of a temporary
precaution that goes away well so look
you how long did you live in China for
two years
maybe not long enough to maybe maybe
long enough to when when they went
through they've had not I don't know if
they've had pandemics but they've had a
variety of outbreaks of things like this
has their behavior yeah like the masks
is a great example so like masks quite
common in Asia to be you know something
you just generally wear out and nobody
even bats eye or seasonally like when
it's flu season yeah everyone masked up
I'm not trying to get the flu and you
know you don't see that here but will
you maybe you will I got I would I would
expect I did I go to crowded movie
theaters they do
yeah there's crowds everywhere in China
you I can't avoid a crowd but you know
yeah like a billion people in a small
city so it's very you know there's
crowds everywhere in China but people do
behave quite differently than they do
here gloves
you know gloves are very sort of common
there that that people here don't wear
gloves just on the day to day life right
so yes I do agree I think things gonna
change I think specifically big cities
are gonna I mean I'm biased because it's
directly impacts me I think cities are
gonna our cities are different right I
do think that work is going to be
different we we're getting rid of our
office yeah exactly so you know there's
all these sort of second order third
order effects example of a second order
effect of the TSA so first order effect
is TSA second order effect is people
selling toothpaste in three ounce
bottles because that's what you need now
to get through that all right that
became a market whatever before who
wants this tiny little bottle and so you
know from I'm just trying to keep it
from a business perspective because you
know from a medical scientific and
cultural perspective you know don't
listen to me with some other people
but from this perspective I think that
there are it is worth you know taking a
pen go into a whiteboard and starting to
map out okay
if this then that and then if that then
what and the what is where your business
opportunity lies and if you're looking
for that it's just a good way to guess
and check even if you're not gonna go do
those things the only way to get your
gut to be good is to predict a bunch of
times and be wrong or right and we'll go
revisit those and so I often do this
role predicting also let's talk about
some talk about some of these
predictions here I pulled it up so some
of these predictions here are so gyms
are gonna go away or significantly go
away and which means innovation and home
exercise obviously that's like at the
dock that's not real quick that's like
just yeah that's I mean that's not even
a question right well I don't think gyms
are gonna go away necessarily but yeah
people are going to whatever the home
exercise market was versus gyms it's
gonna eat more share are you exercising
at home yeah but it's you know I
exercise at home as much as I do at the
gym which is like weak on both fronts
have you oh that's interesting funerals
I don't know
cities will become less popular that's
one of his predictions suburbs and rural
become more popular like oh girl we came
out today and was like you know camping
and RVing is gonna go on the rise
because people still want to travel but
they're not gonna want to travel you
know in dense areas staying and you know
maybe maybe staying in hotels or
uncleaned Airbnb news
yeah I just rented an RV so I'm gonna do
a three week cross-country trip for my
birthday in June so uh yeah I'm I love
that
I completely agree I've never understood
that the first place anyway Americans
are kind of interesting whenever they
like want to do a gap year or like
travel for a honeymoon or ever they
always want to go outside my country I'm
like dog like let's you should explore
here it's way easier and we have
everything that's what's interesting
about America is nobody up every time I
think we're the only country that has
every geography or every climate so
anyway another thing that he talked
about is virtual tours and virtual
museums so on trends we had talked about
a company that was crushing it with
virtual museums and we also talked about
a company that was doing a blow as they
called the VR thing and I remember the
name of it but I know what you're
talking about
sandy our or is that was it sandbox and
I yeah so I I think it's great you're
struggling with this right because
sandbox er you have to go to a physical
place where headset that somebody else
wore an hour before and you know this in
person and and they place their
locations in malls and they're supposed
to be foot traffic from the malls so
foot traffic is dead nobody wants to
wear a device that somebody else just
wore and you know in general this is
like sort of a fringe behavior anyways
and so I talked to yeah I heard from
them that you know they had to be really
conscious about how they're gonna do
this I think they did some layoffs and
whatnot but they you know they have to
figure out how are we gonna survive and
what does the new world look like and so
unfortunately some great ideas and great
businesses you know some markets got
punted back a year or two four years of
whatever it is and some markets got
pulled forward like it's my friend Chris
from first base and they do remote work
set up so you you know everybody now at
home but this wasn't the case when I
started advising him when I started
advising it was like hey I think
companies are going to be going remote
more and if you have a remote employee
they need a desk and a chair and they
need a webcam and they need a microphone
so they can work effectively remotely
maybe companies will pay to give them a
home desk and I was like I don't know
maybe they'll pay maybe they wall and
then boom this thing happened and like
his wait list has exploded thousands of
companies signing up and he can't handle
the demand and now every company has to
have a person like you know at the head
of HR or whatever that is planning how
are we gonna have so many employees
remote and also hey this is extra this
remote thing actually kind of works why
are we paying so much for our office
let's just do this this is way cheaper
and so you know the world has changed
for him then his market got accelerated
by four years yeah I that's incredibly
fascinating I what I think we should do
is we should just link to this this
document is dance there's no way that we
can yeah but I think it's cool I think
it's cool that so do this and that they
just published it as a Google Doc that
anybody can access I think that's just
like a cool way of going
about things and also one that I like on
here one more that I like is Church so
like you know Church was one of the
super spreader type of places where
everybody congregates people often hug
or shake hands or touch and it can
spread throughout a community rapidly if
you if you have churches open and so how
are people gonna do this right history
can go away
no are people gonna go in 6 feet 6 feet
apart maybe I don't know
and so I'm of the opinion that Church
like live streaming for churches is
going to be a very big deal I've been in
the live sharing space for wild so maybe
it's one of those situations where you
know to a hammer everything's a nail and
for me everything can be live-streamed
but no I you know right Church is one of
those things that's every Sunday so
people can build a habit and you know
the experience of a livestream sermon
it's pretty much just as good as being
there it's not that much worse in fact
in many ways the more convenient and you
have all the sort of community features
like chat or donations I mean that's
like what the twitch product is for
example and I researched and there's a
platform called Church online now or
something like that Church online
platform so some horrible name like that
Anoop like a pastor who weren't
programming in his spare time and like
you know sat in the pews and and coded
this thing up like it is so you know
unbranded it backwards in a way but he
said they have 7 million members or
something crazy and you know I guarantee
that's not the best thing that's out
there so for me you know digital faith
is a big thing whether that's sort of
like a next door for churches I don't
know what that means but it sounds
provocative I like it is it is it twitch
for churches is it you know what is it
and so I would be if I was if that meant
something to me if religion meant
something to me I'd be like now is my
time I need to combine technology with
community building and religion and I
need to bring these these real world
institutions online I I'm very good to
see what happens with all that stuff um
speaking of this Korona stuff you have
on our sheet that you want to talk about
outdoorsy
I would love that as well I don't really
know [__] about it I just put it on
there because I'm like interesting and I
didn't do any research so you tell me
about it
okay let me uh the good thing about us
doing this remotely is my computers
right in front of us okay so outdoorsy
it's a it's a peer-to-peer market but
this is the exact description
peer-to-peer marketplace to disrupt the
thirty two billion dollar recreational
vehicle industry okay so they've raised
seventy five million dollars they've
raised a lot of money this what you
notice to rent your or see clearly you
said you just rented RP no because I I
think I'm gonna drive from San Francisco
to New York and then maybe fly back I
have to I have to figure it out I
technically haven't rent it I have a lot
of outgoing quote so I've got people are
gonna be sending me back quote so I
think for outdoorsy it's kind of like
Airbnb where you submit it sometimes you
gotta get approved and so anyway
outdoors he's interesting if you want to
learn about this industry there's
actually um what's that guy's name who's
on that TV show called profit Marcus
Marcus something yeah mark is the profit
I've watched like eight episodes Leonys
yeah or no Lamanna
something like that well anyway a lot of
people don't know this but Marcus is
actually I don't know if he's the
founder I think he like aggregate a
budget or brought a bunch of companies
together so he's the CEO and chairman of
Camping World Good Sam enterprises
Gander outdoors and the house board shop
basically all of this or is around RV
and camping and you can actually go and
read about this company and a lot of
their information is public so you can
kind of see huge business many many
hundreds of millions of dollars in
revenue maybe even hundreds of millions
of dollars in income and so what
outdoorsy is doing is baking is
basically kind of screwing up that model
and I love it I don't know right do you
know what the revenue is um I don't know
outdoors use revenue I think it's quite
high if I remember correctly it's over
100 million let me just do a quick check
let's see yeah we hundred twenty five
million in 2019 Jesus Christ okay it's
meant there's a difference between
revenue and is that their revenue or the
growth bookings that might be there GE
let's assume for a second is there G MV
because marketplaces love to do that so
let's say you
you take 10% of that exactly 32 million
is there cake maybe yeah so they're just
exploding right now eh yeah this is I
mean this is a great business and you
know we talked about before hey market
places are great what are the fringe or
niche market places and this is one of
them right renting RVs you know and now
now is the time and so they're you know
I think they're gonna ride a wave of
interest as people sort of crave being
outdoors crave travel but need to be
away from others
how about hit camp are you familiar with
head camp yeah they're like the same
idea right there like a turnkey glamping
is that right camping camping
experiences camping in the way that I
don't do it where I'm like alright do I
want to learn how to camp and like go
get at REI membership and buy like
hundreds of dollars of stuff and then be
like wet all night like now I'm not into
that but this is like hey you know
sleeping this instagram-worthy tent is
what I remember of it yeah it can be as
easy as that or it can be as difficult
or you can make it as difficult soft or
hard as you want right yeah so you could
just like go and rent like a cabin which
isn't probably camping but or you could
just like get a plotter like an area and
like land and apparently they're booming
as well so they've raised about 50
million dollars and what's interesting
is if you told me about hip hip camp
about two years ago I'd be like this is
not interesting but it is kind of
interesting and there's a I don't know
if this is a company but okay so like I
am like I'm like a a habit I keep
referring to this type of stuff but I
what I always like to do is I like to
look at comparables and I like to look
at public information so do you know
what koa is never heard of it okay so
koa I don't know what it stands for
actually but what it is is it's a it's a
it's a non-profit and they have
campgrounds throughout the country and
if you go to like in Colorado they're
all over the place you'll be on the
highway and you'll see in the same place
you see signs for food you'll see a koa
sign and what that means is if you're a
member you can for I think it's like $20
a years super cheap you can camp there
either for free or for 5 bucks a night
right it's really cheap
and I used to use it all the time when I
was traveling and so according to some
analysts sir I think the privately-owned
they're not nonprofit they do about 40
million dollars a year in sales and they
charge like five bucks right it's like
dirt cheap and so if you want to learn
about that business look up koa that's
probably the best comparable it's a I
can't believe Sean you've never heard of
koa never like okay now it looks great
seems like an obvious idea fantastic
but the what's interesting to me what I
love doing is I love looking at these
older things like koa like Boy Scouts
and it's like show me the demand and
that kind of gives me an idea and then
if you just like add add-ons and operate
it in a in a way where you prioritize
revenue and profit then things get super
interesting and so koa is a really cool
one to look at it's yeah it's it's it's
it's an interesting group and I also
think that in terms of RV I would look
at a Marcus Leona Leo mice's companies
right and you can allow that information
is out there I love it I love hearing
about businesses that I've never heard
of that are successful I feel like
there's a my brain I feel like is
organized like there's a set of hangers
and every hanger I can just hang another
like business or business model onto and
then that's just mapped in my brain and
then when I see something new I'm like
oh is this a new hanger or do I just
attach this to one that already exists
and I start to see a pattern of like oh
yeah there's five things that are just
like this and so that's what I see when
I love hearing about new things just
another thing to hang into my brain have
you um updated your home at all while
you've been at your house I had built a
home office right before Kovac because I
was planning to work remotely anyways
for the month of March which has
happened to be like kovat so that's been
like the only home upgrade and then [__]
started breaking my dishwasher broke and
my dryer broke cuz I'm like that's not
an upgrade yeah that's it
I started go to the park every single
day and I bought these little like tiny
fold-out Park chairs and I have actually
seen several friends buying this same
product called click CLI Q it's a it's
like you know whatever a park chair like
you go to a soccer game you want to
you just want to unfold but the key is
how small and discreet can you make the
the fold in versus like oh [__] I'm
carrying a chair all the way to the park
and I don't know it's gonna arrive soon
but I've seen like I've seen three
different people I know mention this
thing and I bought it myself too before
that I have began spending so I I think
I'm saving like Matt I haven't I
actually ever since the the stock market
crash I have refused to log into my
accounts everything right yeah I sold
though so like my philosophy was I was
like man there's gonna be like dead
bodies in the streets of New York and
that's gonna scare Wall Street and that
someone's gonna take a picture of like a
body and in the like a in the like an
open van with bodies and it's gonna flip
people out and they're gonna like say so
so so and that happened there was like
videos or like these like ice trucks
with like bodies in there and nothing
happened and that day I saw that picture
I was like I'm out right and it took off
a week after and so I'm still sitting on
a lot of cash and I've lost a lot of
money and I hope well I don't hope this
proven right if it goes down and I yeah
if it goes down and I get back in so
anyway I haven't logged in I usually use
I use personal capital and I log in all
the time to check my finances I've not
logged in so I don't entirely know
what's going on but I the other day I
went and bought like eight or maybe
$1,000 worth of artwork because I'm like
I haven't bought anything in forever I'm
just gonna buy exactly I want because
I'm normally pretty cheap and I just
haven't been buying [__] have you been
buying like crazy dude because I shop
online and now I lost track of like time
and space so I'm just buying things and
then there's stuff arriving and it's
like if you can't go anywhere the next
most interesting thing is like someone
comes at your door and leaves a mystery
box at the front you're like oh [__]
what did I order nine days ago I don't
know I'm excited to go see what it is
it's like this moment of fun so I keep
giving myself that gift but yeah buying
a lot of stuff also all the delivery
stuff is like super expensive so I'm
like post
and insta carding and it's like you know
$400 for groceries or something crazy so
I don't know if that's just an SF thing
or I don't know what's going on can we
alright I want to talk about this mark
Leonard guy who you have but before we
get to that have a good segue which is I
I'm gonna get rid of these map I have
okay so little people listening I have a
background and I got maps and which
apparently is like a super basic thing
to do I didn't know that yeah it's like
basic with the capital B st. Louis
Nashville or no st. Louis New York San
Francisco me my wife are from those
areas and I'm gonna switch it up so I
have a a wall of people who I like being
inspired by so yeah so let me tell you
who I have I have Steve Prefontaine you
know who that is ever heard of who's
that there's a movie about him that's
really great you don't to be a runner to
like it but he was a he was a runner at
Oregon he was the first person to wear
Nike so Bill Bowerman
was the coach of Oregon tracker filled
his pupil his his athlete was Phil
Knight together they partnered and made
shoes together Steve Prefontaine was
probably the first person at Wharram he
was or one of and he was definitely the
first sponsored athlete and he was kind
of a badass runner where he was like he
was like kind of like a full clip so he
would say [__] like to give anything
less than your best as a sacrifice your
gift he said all this inspiration stuff
but he died when he was 20 26 and he was
just kind of a rebel too cause then I
have we hold on behind anyway he was
drinking and driving and flipped over
and crashed his car and suffocated okay
so pretty try very very tragic but he
lived fast died young and he it was real
tragic because he got fourth at the
Olympics when he was a favorite even
though he was only 23
anyway it was a big deal he's also like
really good-looking so it's like easy to
like admire him props to you for
admitting that that's part of the appeal
all right great yeah he's like it's like
you know romantic kind of that type of
thing like you kind of look good that I
have eazy-e in dr. Dre okay they're
interesting to me because when eazy-e
was only 23 24 25 something like that he
created ruthless records which went on
to become a huge business like hundreds
of millions of dollars a year in sales
and he was like a kid from Compton who
knew nothing didn't deserve to be there
or did you know like on paper like what
do you
here anyway they achieved it dr. Dre
[__] changed culture in in a variety
of ways then I have Felix Dennis and Ted
Turner Ted Turner started a CNN I like
him Felix Dennis he started a media
company and he was like Richard Branson
but more vulgar google him and then I
have got three more I've got Mike Tyson
I love Mike Tyson he screwed up so many
times in his life he's done a good job
of being ferocious and kind of coming
back and then I've got to Pok and then I
think that's it that's amazing
great oh maybe yes maybe all right so
you have live love Nate yeah you have
like the Intimidators road dude like
it's a the majority of your people fight
for a living or like should fight not
Intimidators rope but I'm incredibly
fascinated with people who are bald
people who on paper should have done
nothing and they did a really good at
having bald ideas but then also we're
having fun along the way right so that's
what I like like Ted Turner I think you
know he was a southerner he stick out
and but he had a bold idea and he
laughed along the way so I'm always
fascinated by that I went to sue Lee's
house where our friend silly and he had
this on his walls like I was like who
are these people but why these pictures
there's not your family and I was like
because if the first one I saw was
Hillary Clinton I was like why do you
configure Clinton on your wall he's like
oh these are people I admire and he had
seven photos and I only knew like three
of the people told me the other before
in a story and it was like Hillary I
don't I was like whoever you know
Malcolm X or Martin Luther King or
something like that another cool idea it
was like you know I guess that's cool
like you know you walk out of your
bedroom every day and you go to your
office or wherever you're going what
does he admire about Hillary Clinton
Hillary Clinton sue Lee don't see me
like Anton I have no idea why you just
think she's also said am i right okay I
guess I mean not even get say like that
she's not awesome but I didn't think
that she was wonderful enough that
exactly what I'm indeed entrepreneur I
was like I don't want to sit here and
hate on Hillary I don't hate Hillary but
I am so surprised she made it to your
wall like that doesn't make any sense I
definitely disagree with that one yeah
so yeah it's just like mediocre maybe so
let's talk about this guy constellation
so I know a bit about them Shawn put
this on here as Billy of the week his
name's mark Leonard
you wanna we sometimes do this
billionaire of the week so the Billy of
the week
is mark Leonard constellation software
so I had heard about this from a few
people because they do something that
you know we had Andrew Wilkinson on here
and he buys internet businesses and sort
of has this conglomerate of small
internet business that he's collected
that are now you know let's call it a
hundred million dollars worth or maybe a
little more a little less and that's a
fantastic success so this guy mark
Leonard did that like he's Andrews daddy
you know like his company's worth thirty
1 billion dollars what they do is they
buy software companies and they roll
them up sort of and they're they try to
be a perpetual owner so they're not like
they're not private equity where they're
doing a leveraged buyout and trying to
flip you know kind of skin it and flip
it or whatever they tried to just own
the thing for a long period of time and
had the cash flows and so what I like
about this guy what I thought was cool
was this guy's like a Satoshi Nakamoto
of boring businesses so he nobody knows
[__] about this guy you can't find a
photo wait what's that reference the
Bitcoin guy yeah you just don't know a
lot about I guess so so this guy you
can't find photos of them he doesn't do
public appearances he doesn't really
talk he writes his annual letter and you
know but so I was reading like kind of
the definitive thing about him because I
wanted to learn and it's like all we
know is this guy's born in 1956 maybe in
South Africa maybe in England I was like
what the [__] we don't even know where
this guy's from and you know he's wrote
on his bio he's like it was a VC but
before that he said I was a banker
evaluator a Mason a gravedigger a dog
handler a bouncer a sapper and and wind
energy researcher I particularly enjoyed
the bouncing but an early retirement was
necessary so I love it that I don't know
anything about this guy but we came and
I think half those are like a joke but
here's their business so they buy in the
early on they buy they bought businesses
that were you know two to four million
dollar acquisition target so very small
acquisition which is which is on paper
you would say that's asinine my own yeah
chump change you know okay well you know
small ball but small ball is turn into
sort of big league returns
and so you know this data is out of date
now because when the article I was
reading was like hey this guy has you
know done really well they did last year
they had 1.2 billion in sales 20%
margins they're doing 10 to 20
acquisitions a year and at that time the
market camp was 5 billion I looked at it
while I was reading the article it's now
31 billion and so if you're just
invested in ok guys it they have a
thirty 1 billion dollar valuation and
only 1.2 and that was the old one when
they were at five billion market cap now
they're at 31 billion market cap so you
know if the ratio sort of held held the
same it'd be whatever six seven billion
in sales we can see we can see what it
is now but I love that this guy's
mysterious I love dude it's only it's
only it's three billion their sales were
only three billion dollars so a lot of
money but that's not a got a good little
I wonder I wonder why doing on such the
run up because you can see the stock
chart is like you know it's going up
like crazy and then they can use that
money for for acquisitions and this guy
he writes these annual letters that are
actually pretty interesting so like if
you're like me you I like to read Bezos
his annual letter I like to read Warren
Buffett's annual letters this guy is a
new one I'm adding to the sort of
arsenal of annual letters and he has a
lots of really interesting sort of views
on business and then of which are like
totally groundbreaking but he does
something that I think most people fail
to do which is the same thing Warren
Buffett does which is take a very simple
principle that everybody would nod their
head and agree with and then like
actually stick to it and do it for like
40 years and that's like a winning
formula most people you know nod their
head and then go do some other [__] and
they get there under lack of discipline
than lack of focus and so I also like
you know trying to read a little bit
more about the company and you know they
have sort of a focus on what they call
vertical software so they'll go for like
within one vertical are sorry they
looked at they said hey some companies
are horizontal like a slack every
company can use slack as a messaging
service and slack will be a
multi-billion dollar company but what
about all these vertical things that are
like better software specifically
tailored software for uh you know what
if you're a golf club you need to manage
bookings T times memberships and
whatever else every golf club you will
pretty much use whatever the best
software is and they'll pay for it
everybody every month reliable
you'll never churn so they'll buy like
that Clubhouse software they'll buy
healthcare software public transit
software law software and that's been
their focus I don't know if that's
change over time but when I was reading
about them they try to consolidate
vertical market software which I thought
was a pretty interesting approach what
do you think of this guy I love it I'm
reading about what you have here so I
love doing these things and I love that
what he's doing and I actually I'm gonna
bring up a different point and I don't
want to address it yet but I want to ask
your opinion of it in a second but more
so what I'm interested in is tonight I
don't want to refer to like things I
tweeted that sounds super lame but I was
tweeting earlier about how I hired an
operator so basically Adam Ryan works at
the company and he kind of handles a lot
of the operational stuff and I work
sometimes down in the weeds sometimes
high up revisions up and it's hard
finding someone who's competent to run a
business and so if this if this guy it's
if he might have I would just say I'm in
companies he has it could be like 200
right so I don't know if their model is
really keep the existing management or
if they replace them I'm not I'm not one
percent sure what they do I'm sure
there's some some mix and blend there
one thing I saw that was interesting was
so they like Berkshire Hathaway the
execs of the companies do not get share
options as their compensation which
basically you know incentivizes you just
boost the share prices as you as much as
you can which is often somewhat
short-term so instead they take you know
75% of their after-tax bonus and they
can buy shares on the open market and
then those shares are held in escrow for
four years so if the shares if the stock
is overvalued because they are sort of
temporarily pumping you know enthusiasm
energy or doing buybacks or whatever
they're buying overvalued stock and so I
don't know if this is perfect cuz maybe
the other thing happens where they
actually you know when they're about to
buy they sort of oh you know bad news
dips the state share price temporarily
they could buy it on the discount so I'm
not sure if any incentive system is
perfect but I thought it was interesting
that they've thought through how should
we compensate everybody and and not sort
of follow the traditional playbook so I
want to dig in more I've
just scratched the surface of this guy I
think there's a lot to learn here but I
wanted to bring it up because I think
it's very interesting and I like that
he's a sort of mysterious character I
think that adds to it so here's an
interesting take away and in this what
I'm about to say actually kind of
changed my business game and I'm gonna
name-drop here but when Tim Ferriss
invested in us he told me he goes one
thing that I've learned from I don't
know who we learned it from but he goes
there's this thing that I like to use
called um did he I think he called it
inverse incentives or but basically the
idea is if you when you incentivize
employees to do something you need to
actually have an opposite incentive that
makes sure it's balanced so for example
if you're gonna tell your sales team you
have a quota of this number and it's
huge you also have to have an incentive
it's kind of like revenue collections
which means you only go after quality
people who can pay bills or RAM
retention which is you only get paid if
you sell people and you're you treat
them well and they want to come back to
basically and so yeah a counter
incentives I think that's what they
called it uh and that actually changed
the game for me a lot because what I've
noticed is with people if you give
driven people incentives the right type
of person will kill to get that done and
you want those input you you want those
people but you actually really need like
that second incentive in order to make
sure that it's quality and quantity and
so I love this incentive but what I want
to know is how on earth did they recruit
all these people who are talented enough
to run a business
I've hired CEOs for a handful of small
businesses that I've had most all except
for one or two have been horrible yeah
and which maybe I'm hiring but I think
it was also it's really hard to find
these types of people and so in my mind
this company constellation they're more
like a recruiting company than an
innovative software company yeah you
know I think that is sort of the
make-or-break I think you also invested
in in our friends who are doing enduring
ventures and so these guys are basically
starting a modern-day version of
constellation or what Andrew is doing or
whatever where they're flying companies
to hold forever that have strong cash
flows and they want to own great
businesses and you know they've already
closed they bought the first business
they bought was a business
up Council ironically I believe this was
sort of outside the model which is you
know my point earlier of say a simple
thing nod your head and agree and then
go [__] do it I think that they did
not do that with up council because up
council was not a great business it was
a it's a potentially great business but
it was currently sort of in a rotten
rocky waters but they got that it's such
a great deal and they structured the
deal in such a smart way that I think
they'll still end up making a lot of
money from it but anyways you know
they're doing the same same sort of
thing and their biggest challenges is is
how do you find operators so when they
bought up council you know the CEO that
they placed was you know you know
somebody the Savior had worked with and
knew knew very very well anyway they
brought in a team of operators but you
know they're pulling from their personal
networks that's what Andrew said he did
as well which was he pulled from people
he knew or you had worked with before in
the past but I think that is the the
largest challenge with this business
model is being able to maintain a keep a
great business a great business by
having good operators in place because
when you buy out the owner sometimes you
may lose that great operations and if
this interests you I think that there's
a few giants that you can look up and
one of them is AltaVista or Navi so
that's a not that visa equity it's owned
by this guy named Robert Moore I believe
he's the richest black man in America
he is the guy who's famous for what he's
well he's the guy who's famous for
paying the tuition of everyone at
Morehouse when he gave a an address he
said by the way all your guys does debt
paid off so he's he's cool but that's
what he does he does the same thing as
does trilogy software so look up Joe
Lamont who we've talked about all right
you want to talk about oh here's what
I'm gonna talk about ok so there's these
companies like Tesla and basically a lot
of stuff that Elon does which is like
this like super sexy stuff I mean I'm
not interested in in it but it is quite
sexy to say you're gonna send a
you're gonna go to Mars or you're
creating these cars that are neat and
fun and that whenever I think about
these companies they're like the coolest
companies where you create a hype video
at the end of the year and you see
everything they've done and you're like
oh my god that's so sick
like when they created like a video of
Elon celebrating the one of his rockets
taking off I was like and so anyway
constellations not that he doesn't do a
video of him like looking at his golf
club software right and it's pretty
boring but it's still fascinating
because like a fun puzzle how do you
Shawn about like where are your
aspirations like do you say like I want
to do something that's full of
excitement or do you find excitement in
the boring so I used to be a pretty
hardcore about this where I was like
dude the only thing worth doing like if
I'm gonna spend my time and I used to be
really like dismissive of people who
were wasting their time doing things
that were not sort of the peak of the
peak so I was like okay I'm gonna do why
would I do a job when I can own my own
business then I was like why would I own
a small business when I can own a big
business they're both gonna take up all
my energy my time and as I can I'm gonna
do a big business why would I do a
boring thing might as well do an
exciting thing and that train of logic
made sense to me and I did that so at
Monkey inferno it was we are here to try
to create the next hit consumer thing
we're like we don't give a [__] that
that's low odds of success we want to
create you know Michael had created Bebo
and which was like sort of like almost
Facebook yeah it's like come with in
sort of inches of creating a Facebook
but instead ended up in the myspace pile
and you know did well financially but he
didn't change culture and so we were
like dude we can do this we could change
culture and so we tried every you know
messaging apps live-streaming we tried
all these different consumer things and
failed like crazy and you know even
things that like kind of worked they
ultimately were not successful because
there was they were so homerun driven
they were grand-slam driven so I backed
off that and I backed off that maybe
because I'm just burnt dude I just want
to get wins like I don't need to change
culture like I didn't need to change my
bank account and my lifestyle like so I
don't know to what extent I'm it's it's
like I can frame it either way am i more
mature because I'm like look I don't
I have I'm not as attracted to the
sexiness of it I just want to build you
know great things great businesses or am
I just fearful and burnt out from
failure it's hard to say for me right
but my view definitely has changed where
now I'm like oh that you on path I don't
know that sounds like a lot of effort
why don't I just do this simple thing
that's gonna like work yeah and part of
me is like okay I agree and I agree and
I am the same and then the other part is
like yeah dude but you're just kind of
being like a puss like what would the
twelve-year-old in you like think is
awesome and every once in a while you
gotta listen to that and so I don't know
how I feel like because the other day I
was thinking about making a purchase and
I I sound like a like a kind of entitled
rich dude right now which I'm not
implying I am either of those things
but I was gonna buy like a car like a
cool car and it wasn't expensive it was
like a ten thousand dollar car and it
was not practical and I was like
weighing the like pros and cons of it
and then I was like yeah but here's this
Pro which is like this is fun and cool
and I want it right right and I'm like
what did I could become such an old man
like where I'm not just doing [__] just
because it's exciting and I do think
that like you we have to give in to
those urges a little bit more you
laundries anyway about this I think on
was but he was I was talking about he
was like yeah like Warren Buffett like
he's like I'm not a huge fan of the guy
not the biggest fan but he didn't say he
disliked him but he was like you know
what he does he's a capital allocator
like he spends his time trying to figure
out do I buy dope whirring today he's
like yeah he's like put ten billion
dollars into Pepsi or coke he's like
yeah like that's boring to me like I
want to change the world and you know
I'm gonna make cars electric so we don't
have to depend on fossil fuels and I'm
gonna get us to Mars
so we're interplanetary species and I'm
gonna do neural link so that our brain
can control you know you know a brain
can download information and upload
information like we're a computer in the
brain and I'm gonna do boring company
cuz I [__] hate traffic and I want to
get you know from place to place and you
know
fifteen minutes rather than two hours
and I'm like okay you know respect like
when you hear that you're like yeah that
does seem like the maximum of winning
but you know I guess my view is my views
have broadened but I'm like you wear
when I hear myself say it I'm like don't
be a [__] dude just like come on go for
it don't do what you would do at the
beginning you know like don't don't lose
that sort of dream just because of
practicality so I'm a fan of motorsports
and motorcycles and I like like some of
these adrenaline stuff I like old
Porsches and all these exciting things
and I see these guys on YouTube like ken
black and he's got this like compound or
I'll see like travis Pastrana and he's
got this compound it's just like
grown-up playground and I'm like oh one
day that would be cool and then I'm like
no no no no now like why why can't I
just do that [__] now and I so I
constantly have to battle that in my
head and so it sounds like yeah it is
about I have what's prudent like prudent
versus like excitement and the balance
between the two okay let's let's leave
with one or two little ideas real quick
all right so I have one idea so are you
familiar with kin duo duo okay no this
is one of the largest companies in China
I think like a 30 billion dollar company
that grew in the last four years or so
all those numbers could be wrong but you
get the idea
big-ass Chinese company so what the hell
is pin do it do it pin do is like
Groupon but it's with your friends so
what happens is you go on pin do a duo
and there's like an item the number one
selling item tissue boxes number two
selling item is like a vacuum or some
[__] but it'll be like tissue boxes
here's these two boxes you can get them
for let's say you know $20 you can get
these tissue boxes but if you buy with
your friends you can all get them for
eight and it's like create a team to buy
and so you see the item you want you
create a team the way you create a team
is it just gives you a link and you
share that link through WeChat or
whatever your messaging apps are and if
your friends are like yeah cool I'll
join the group I'll buy an eight like
I'll pitch I will contribute to the
cause helping you get a lower price and
I get a lower price too
there's these team buys basically so
this thing has become really really
popular in China and I don't think it's
become popular really anywhere else I
know there's a couple of companies
trying to do this in India as well and
like you know God knows Indians love a
good discount so I do think this will
work in India as well but I was thinking
about this so I was like okay you know
if I was an entrepreneur you know just
sitting on my you know my desk and there
was nothing on my desk I would just
write the word pen duo duo for X and I
would just figure out what the hell X is
I would spend a day on that brainstorm
and so so bright I love it
can I give you sure you don't I know I
like listening to it while you're
talking I'm like it might have my brain
it wasn't so you know tilt comm tilt got
tilt fault it was a joker it was called
up tilt so James tried to watch this he
raised a lot of money it crashed and
burned was crowd talk was not a discount
it was just hey we need $500 for a
kegger everybody pitch in your 10 bucks
if you're gonna come to the party so it
was a way to collect million but it
wasn't discounting you're right
so let's get rid of them drop do you
know drop formally from known as mass
drop they do that's right so I have yeah
kinda it's similar you know you know I
think to make this work it's all about
the packaging and the positioning like
so mass drop and this other company can
offer the same technology do the same
thing but you really got a it's really
you gotta get that angle exactly right I
think and mass drop has is trying this
and from my friends who have inside
information which I don't have
they claim that mass drop is booming
mass drop has raised close to 50 million
bucks and everyone I talked to who is
knows about the space says that it's a
sleeper and it's doing wonderful and
they do a little bit similar stuff so I
think that that's cool another bit of
information is something like master
class so master class actually allows
you to share passwords to one or two
people and someone someone in our trends
group
said about it and said like hey does
anyone want to split master class with
me and it was our most engaged post ever
right and so I completely see the
validation here this is incredible so
yeah and back in the day I think woot
was like this and there were some others
where it's like hey this TV is you know
cheap and they it wasn't exactly like it
wasn't the exactly the same I think the
magic of this is that it's your actual
friend group that you use to do this so
with the problem with Groupon and all
these others is you get to deal hunter
so there's just this population of deal
hunters they're getting everything at a
discount and they're not necessarily
like the best customers long-term
they're not retaining a long-term all
that stuff what's cool about this is you
know one of the challenges for any
business is you have to acquire
customers so here's how I would do this
today I think you can create pin duo duo
for Shopify what does that mean so
there's all these Shopify stores out of
them let's call it a hundred thousand
Shopify stores every single one of these
Shopify stores wants more customers
they'll try to get those customers
through either Google SEO or Facebook
Ads two primary ways and then
word-of-mouth let's say let's beyond
that so you know they go and they go to
Facebook and they'll pay $15 for a
customer to come purchase from them if
they want another customer they got to
go pay another $15 and that's
unfortunate right and they'll offer
discounts and they'll try to do a
referral program or whatever but what I
think they should do is one of the
largest sort of booms in Shopify is this
thing called after pay or a firm which
basically says hey when you're checking
out instead of paying $85 for this you
can do monthly payments for nine dollars
and that increase the checkout rate
because people can pal at nine dollars a
month better than they they can do $90
today upfront and so adding an after pay
button increased sales so I think if you
added a buy together save together
button you would increase sales so the
way it works is you're about to check
out and it says great you can either
have this item for $80 but if you get
five friends to buy you all get it for
60 you're you all get it for 50 or
whatever it is some discount there and
you basically are saying rather than
paying $15 per customer and Facebook Ads
I will pay you know 15 I'll pay 10
dollars right now to discount this item
for you because you're gonna go acquire
five
customers for me right so like if I
reduced it and I'm you know I'm
basically producing like my cost by are
my my revenue by 20 20 bucks per
customer I'm able to sort of acquire
customers through a new channel besides
Facebook Ads which is sort of steadily
price rising over time and also the way
that if you get introduced to a product
through a friend I think you sort of
have a better relationship with the
product and better experience better
retention than if you are only being
advertised through by the company so I
would try fit I think this is I think
this is the best it's very hard very
hard because you have to you're building
something from scratch here and it's all
about like this is this is definitely a
all-or-nothing type of thing in my mind
where you have to get the positioning
really really right and but I think if
you do you're onto something right you
know it's it's kind of its kind of like
a live streaming thing it's like live
streaming isn't like hard to make I mean
there's so many of them but you really
got to find that angle that like it gets
people this is more big business than
small certain success big business most
likely to fail the other thing that I
think is interesting here I think that's
thing about Shopify and I was like okay
what other buttons would I put at
checkout that I could basically offer
that's a great that's a great framework
so like for example in mobile games they
do this all the time you run out of
lives and it's like hey you could buy
another life you can share this with a
friend and get in our life or you can
watch this 30-second ad and get in our
life so the mobile games are like you
know it's like a little you know wizard
sitting inside a slot machine just
trying to figure out how to take your
money your time or attention and they've
optimized the [__] out of this and so
what can you learn from that so maybe if
you're at Shopify or you have a Shopify
store maybe there's a plug-in that you
can add to your checkout which says hey
if you want an extra you know dollar off
or $2 off just click this button and
like us on Instagram and boom now my
Instagram is growing with every customer
that joints or whatever yeah there's a
bunch of there's definitely a bunch of
tools that allow you to do that but I
entered the most popular one is email
like give us your email and you get a
you get a 15% off or whatever and I
think that's cool that's like level one
but like this idea of team buying of
sharing to your Instagram liking us on
Instagram I think there's just more
things that you could do at the checkout
page that would say how do I get your
time money or
in some way that you're not currently
giving me and so I don't know if there's
there's a lot there because Shopify so
big now that if you build something that
works on Shopify you can build a you
know 10 million 20 million dollar
business pretty quickly because every
store will just adopt these like best
practices fairly quickly I think that
first thing your time up group buying is
incredibly interesting I've always
thought that group hon I love Groupon I
think that their valuation is [__] and
I'm like that there's gotta be a better
way to make that happen and I love
coupon I love group Hana I'm also
familiar with appSumo which does group
discounting for software and then social
stack I think it's called great comedies
where else could you do group buying is
there any other like sort of space like
absolute was a great example where
they're like okay cool sort of software
are there like I don't know you well so
a lot of this stuff has been tried and
it doesn't always work but you
definitely could do it I mean this is
what Kickstarter is right you did it
with brand end of brand their land kept
a tilt we have to cross this threshold
and I don't know what it could work for
I'd have to really think about it I just
I feel so ignorant on what works or not
the thing about it is it works better
when the thing cost the maker nothing
then when it costs to make or something
right so software is great because every
incremental sale of a piece of software
cost the maker zero vs. like if it's a
physical item and like well now I'm
every TV if the more people that buy
this the more people more TVs I have to
sell out at loss and so I think digital
works better than physical
that's one like premise I would make I
would I would hold what when it comes to
this and I mean the other one is like
where maybe I don't know if it works
better for low price probably higher
priced items because a the discount
matters and B maybe there's just more
margin you know to be captured even
after discount verses and low price item
so maybe you would be looking for sort
of high price digital digital services
software yeah
I mean I think that you could definitely
what about using it so what I would want
to use it for what businesses buy so
like for example I want to buy pitch
book but it's 20 grand a year and I'm
not gonna use it that much but I would
love to split it with someone so I think
that's incredibly interesting one weird
idea is I think that I would want to
figure out a way to use it for lawyers
so instead of having a legal firm be my
lawyer I split a lawyer with you and
five other people and that that by
that's a great name split it or split it
would be a great name for a company that
was trying to do this it's like hey you
can do this but or you want you want to
split it with four others and hey you
all save you have to have a ton of
volume to make this work the way you
could make then is if you make it to
that cool let's say the price is a
hundred bucks and if I'm gonna split it
with five people I think what ends up
happening is that everybody gives it for
less than 100 but the total adds up to
more than 100 right like like they're
totally I end up making more than I
would have off of a single customer
paying full price by by letting you
great it looks good at first for 70 and
now I get 140 and you get hundred right
it's like how personal trainer does
group training they're like if you want
one-on-one it's a hundred dollars an
hour if there's two of you guys you each
pay 70 bucks an hour and it's like I now
make more per L it's a great idea that's
a great idea I love split it I'm never
gonna create this because that it seems
way too hard but I understand the need
in the problem and I would love to be
involved and as a customer or some
capacity great all right split your
brain some rain we'll be back in a
couple days with another brain storm
people said you can't keep up this pace
how can you keep coming up with new
ideas every week twice a week are you
crazy
but they don't understand they don't
know how this brain works did if you
spend enough time doing it which we
definitely don't always do but a lot of
times we do it is not and if you lower
the bar on what you call an interesting
or good idea so I know things you lower
the expectations and practice that is
the that is a criteria it's that easy
leave us review tell us what you think
tweet at us or whatever we're talking
about
[Music]